this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
i've been using apple's 59 magsafe
wallet
almost every single day since it came
out but i've realized that we've never
done a review or even a dedicated video
on it
and i've actually changed my mind about
it since i've last commented on it in a
video so let's go ahead and talk about
if you should spend
59 of your hard-earned dollars on it or
if you should buy
one of the much cheaper third-party
options like this one
which you can buy on amazon for as low
as 10 dollars with prime shipping
or possibly a nicer one like the moft
wallet which i'll link to
down in the description or just stick
with the wallet that you already have
let me quickly start
out with the announcement of mac safe
and my initial
thoughts almost no one was expecting
apple
to stuff their iphone 12s with the ring
of magnets that fixed
probably the biggest problem with
wireless charging when apple showed it
off
both vadim and i were instantly
intrigued by this new tech
we both love wireless charging and use
it daily
but those mornings when i woke up to a
dead phone
because i didn't align my phone
perfectly were extremely annoying
and of course the slow charging speeds
also suck
if you want to top off your phone during
the day vadim did a deep dive into
magsafe after the announcement
calling it apple's master plan to be
honest
i was nowhere near as optimistic about
it but after
four months i have to say that i now
completely agree with basically
everything he said you should definitely
check out that video after this one
getting back to the wallet i was
skeptical about it
actually probably more than that i
thought it was a dumb idea
now sure for cases having max 8 that
will hold your case on
without having a super tight fit
required is great
and the same thing for aligning chargers
but a super slim wallet that can barely
hold
any cards seemed dumb and then i
saw the 59 dollar price tag
was apple crazy well maybe they were
or maybe i am because of course i did
order one
to be even more honest after receiving
it and opening up the box for the first
time
i was almost sure that i was going to
return it for a number of reasons
first off i already had a slim wallet
that held four cards
and a bit of cash this only held three
cards in no cash
but at the same time the three cards
barely fit inside of it
and it was literally frustrating every
time i needed to get one of my cards out
and lastly the magnet was quite a bit
weaker than i expected
when i first started putting it into my
pocket i would have issues with the
wallet twisting off
and at times falling off and after the
first day or two
just like many others online i pretty
much wrote the wallet off
as a complete failure from apple that
they would either have to fix
or discontinue so why is it that four
months later
i am still using the wallet well my
journey
to loving this wallet was quite
interesting and i'll explain why
right after a quick shout out to the
sponsor of this video squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website now is the perfect time
and squarespace is seriously the best
way to go
you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally
no web making experience it doesn't
matter if you want a portfolio
a blog e-commerce or anything else you
just choose a template and you customize
blocks of text and images
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
and ours have been running flawlessly
for years now
bringing in lots of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.commaxtech
or use our custom link down below and
when you're ready to launch you will
save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain my first week or so with the
wallet was quite frustrating
and i still planned on returning it but
i was slowly starting to get used to
handling it in a way that kept the
wallet on the back
of my phone i started to put the phone
into my pocket differently making sure
to pull the pocket
open with a finger before i let the
phone drop in and
if you wear loose pants it's not really
as bad but with tighter ones especially
ones that you have to kind of force the
phone down
you definitely have to be very careful
pulling the phone out
is a little bit more tricky as you kind
of need to hold the wallet slightly when
you pull your phone out
especially with larger phones or else
the wallet can twist
and stay in your pocket but that's more
of an annoyance
not really a risky issue being able to
lose it
then comes the issue of pulling cards
out of the tight wallet
if you have two cards in there you're
fine but with three i found that you
need to place
one card that has punched out numbers
inward so that you can grip them
when taking your cards out so with all
of these issues and annoyances why would
i still recommend buying one of these
well once you get used to its
intricacies it starts to become
very convenient but before it got better
it got even
worse a few weeks after the 12 pro was
released i switched over to the new 12
pro max
and i brought the wallet over as well
this is where the frustration went to a
whole other level and this is the one
phone that i probably wouldn't
highly recommend this wallet for even
though i'm still using it
daily the magnets are the same exact
strength as in
all of the other 12 so you wouldn't
think that they would be any different
but the magsafe wallet comes off of the
12 pro max way
easier than the rest of the iphones at
first i thought there was something
wrong
with my max but other max leaf
accessories had no issues
so it's definitely the combo of the two
after a bit i figured out that there
are two reasons why it sucks with the
max
the first reason is that it has a matte
texture on the back of the phone
because of this the kind of slick
texture of the wallet slides fairly
easily
much more so than with the regular 12
which has a glossy back
of course the standard 12 pro also has a
map back but it stays on that phone
much better and that's because of how
much space there is between the edge of
the frame
and where the wallet sits on the max
because of this
your finger or really anything else can
be in that space
and then if it slightly bumps or pushes
against the wallet
that just causes it to very easily spin
and as soon as it spins the bottom
strips of magsafe unalign
and then it is much easier for the
wallet to pop off
and this happens way too often i was
starting to get quite annoyed with it
and then came time to test out the
iphone 12 mini
and i absolutely fell in love with the
wallet combining the glossy back of the
phone with the size
which fits the wallet perfectly resulted
in the wallet
literally not moving at all it became
a whole nother experience with me not
having to worry about the wallet
and it made the phone a lot more
comfortable as well filling in the gap
between my hand and the back of the
phone
i would keep it on most of the time and
when i didn't need my wallet i would pop
it off
and leave it in my other pocket giving
me the best flexibility between having
my phone
and wallet in one package and having a
super slim wallet that isn't noticeable
in my pants or
jacket pocket when i don't need it
together so if you have a standard
iphone 12
or especially an iphone 12 mini and
you're considering buying an apple
wallet
i would highly recommend it and if you
have a 12
pro the experience is still fairly good
but with that said
what if you're like me and you have a 12
pro max
well it really depends on three things
the first
is why you want to buy one if you want
to keep it on your phone at all times
i probably wouldn't recommend it unless
you're really careful with your phone
because of how easily it can pop off i
think that you're probably better off
with a case that can hold credit cards
the second reason to buy it is a much
bigger deal
and that's if you want to hold cards on
there often but you also want to use
max save chargers and stands in that
scenario it is so much easier to pop
off a wallet than a case when you want
to use a vent mount or a charger like i
do
which i have been absolutely loving max
8 for
the third reason might seem dumb but
stay with me and let me know in the
comments if you're like me
and you have a hard time keeping your
wallet slim
i've been struggling with this for years
where i keep adding
more and more cards receipts and other
stuff
into my wallet until it is massive and
then my jeans end up getting marks on
them
from having such a huge wallet there i
tried
to break this annoying habit by getting
myself a slim wallet
and it definitely helped but i still
kept adding more cards and junk
into it and i ended up stretching it out
and then i kept having to offload
stuff from it every once in a while when
it got too big
when i went back to the 12 pro max from
the mini i ended up ditching the wallet
for a few days
and using my slim one again but i found
that i missed having such
a minimalist wallet for multiple reasons
of course
it stayed slim because i only had my
necessities in there like my id
and a few cards and i used apple pay for
the rest
and i also missed having it on the back
of the 12 pro max because of how much
extra grip it adds
when you're holding the phone it's
almost like having a case that doesn't
make your phone any wider
since it adds some grip and it also
allows the phone to sit flat when i set
it down so i don't risk scratching the
back or the lenses
and it doesn't wobble from the camera
bump with that i can easily take it off
whenever i want a slimmer phone or to
charge
and like i said my wallet stays nice and
thin
all the time so even though it works by
far
the worst on the 12 pro max after
getting used to taking it out and
putting it into my pocket carefully
and being cautious about how easily it
can twist off
it's definitely one of my favorite
accessories for the iphone 12
and i think that judging by the huge
amount of stellar reviews on amazon
most people would agree with me that
even though it's priced ridiculously
high
at 59 if you can forget about the price
it's worth it so what about if you want
a slim minimalist wallet for your 12 but
you don't want to spend that much money
should you buy a third-party wallet one
that looks basically the same
minus the apple logo but costs 1 6 of
the price
like this one no definitely don't
we reviewed this one in our top 10 max
safe accessories video and even though
it was cheap
it has multiple issues the first one is
that it is fake
leather and it's even more slippery on
the back of your phone
and it only fits two cards inside with
that if you thought apple's max safe
magnets were too weak
this one is probably only about a third
of the strength
and it comes off even off of the iphone
12
very easily where the actual genuine
apple wallet
basically doesn't move at all i
personally think that it's not even
worth
10 now of course we do have more options
out there more expensive ones like the
moft wallet
but i haven't personally tried that one
out there's also more coming out soon
so if you want me to do a wallet
comparison hit that like button and
leave a comment down below
if we have enough interest i'll order a
variety of them and test them out and
make a video for you guys
so overall if you guys are looking to
ditch your wallet and you want the
convenience and benefit of having it
being able to
stick to your phone i would say go for
it and actually i would suggest
ordering one from amazon so you get a
30-day return policy with no questions
asked
just in case you don't end up liking it
for me
this wallet and other mac safe
accessories are now killer features of
the iphone
and it will make it even harder to
change to another phone
if you guys want to see vadim's apple's
master plan video or my review of my
favorite charging stand they are right
over there
and go ahead and click that circle above
to help us reach our goal of 600 000
subscribers before our two-year mark
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video